I could either save money or I could  just wow those look good  should we get some I don't know they're  pretty gay we're gay all right fine  excuse me sir two of those fruity drinks  please good call yeah these are amazing  how does this look  it looks good that's why I bought it  yeah mm-hmm as long as you don't do that  how would you like to let it  are you scrolling through some random  guys Instagram right now yeah but look  how hot he is oh my god he is hot wait  click on the show this one wait what's  his handle wait did you wash your hands  no come on might be a little spoon it's  one more minute it's my turn  nice we got clean swole bro don't stop  don't stop can you believe marriage  equality only passed two years ago I  know it really makes you think huh I  love you I love you too  [Music]